[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in allen der grunewald ist
viel mehr als
4500 hektar baumbestand er ist
erholungsort für eine metropole grüne
lunge von berlin geliebt und besungen
und jetzt steht er in flammen was diesen
waldbrand am rande der großstadt
besonders bedrohlich macht ist ein depot
der polizei mit sprengstoff und munition
mitten zwischen den bäumen die feuerwehr
kann sich deshalb nur vorsichtig näher
an abos autobahnen und bahnstrecken sind
komplett gesperrt christhard läpple mit
mehr
bilder wie aus dem krieg
explosionen am frühen morgen es brennt
nicht irgendwo nein mitten im berliner
grunewald mitten auf einem abgesperrten
sprengplatz feuerwerkskörper und
kriegsmunition in flammen den wald
wir treffen einen radfahrer der parallel
zur autobahn a bus auf dem weg zur
arbeit war er traute seinen augen nicht
macht mir richtig angst macht mir
richtig sorgen man denkt immer diese
globale erwärmung geht an einem vorbei
und ich bin jetzt und wie selbst
betroffen es ist sehr dicht schauplatz
berlins grüne lunge der krone wald
dichtern der avus und einer
vielbefahrenen bahnstrecke
der wald ist knochentrocken und
ausgebaut nur hetze kein regen
ausgerechnet am sprengplatz nimmt das
unglück um 33 seinen lauf mitten in der
nacht einsatzkräfte wollen löschen
können aber nicht den ganzen tag über
bis zum abend wir gehen davon aus dass
der boden und die dame belastung am
sprengplatz noch enorm groß ist sonst
wäre es vermutlich auch nicht 14 stunden
nach der ersten alarmierung zu einer
detonation so wie jetzt gerade im
hintergrund gekommen es sind daher
massive geräusche der 1000 meter
sperrkreis bleibt bestehen
es brennt weiter die ursache ist unklar
die rund 250 einsatzkräfte können
derzeit nichts anderes tun als den
brandherd großräumig zu sichern sie
hoffen dass nichts schlimmeres passiert
die avus bis morgen 6 uhr gesperrt die
gretchenfrage wie sinnvoll ist ein
springplatz mit einem kohle wald nach
polizeiangaben lagern rund 25 tonnen
sprengmaterial unter anderem
weltkriegsmunition und feuerwerkskörper
experten machten sie dort unschädlich
die regierende bürgermeisterin alte
extra aus dem urlaub zum tatort es
handelt sich hier tatsächlich um ein
ereignis das in der berliner
nachkriegsgeschichte
einmalig ist der grunewald ist hier um
diesen spreng plätze um in flammen
geraten
schon lange wurde in berlin gefordert
den springplatz zu schließen
wir müssen uns eher darüber gedanken
machen wie wir in zukunft mit diesem
sprengplatz umgehen und ob auf berliner
stadtgebiet ein solcher ort der richtige
ist er soll in großer not helfen theodor
ein roboter des lka er kann in der
brennenden sperrzone sprengstoff
entdecken bewerten und beseitigen doch
auch der roboter stößt an grenzen
genauso wie die löschflugzeuge
selbst der luftraum über dem springplatz
ist in einer höhe bis zu 1000 metern
gesperrt uns muss bewusst sein dass
jeder meter den wir diesen sperrkreis
rein gehen die einsatzkräfte eine gefahr
darstellt insofern ist die
lageentwicklung jetzt so dass wir damit
rechnet werden dass wir in den dachstuhl
immer wieder auch noch dekoration
eventuell hören können und den
sprengplatz morgen früh frühestens
wieder leute gehen werden die einzig
gute nachricht aus berlin an diesem
heißen augusttag
menschenleben waren nicht in gefahr
berlins landesbranddirektor ist vor ort
und jetzt bei uns live im zdf kasten
homrighausen guten abend herr
haben ihre leute das feuer der
mittlerweile unter kontrolle
na ja wir sind immer noch in der
situation dass um den sprengplatz der
polizei berlin ein sperrbereich eine
sperrzone eingerichtet ist eine
sperrzone mit einem radius von einem
kilometer und wir weil halt keine
menschen in gefahr sind halt auch noch
nicht in diese sperrzone vordringen um
die brandbekämpfung einzuleiten das
heißt wir sind hier noch in der abwarten
in stellung wir bekämpfen natürlich
brände die über diese sperrzone
hinausgehen sollten sind aber noch
darauf angewiesen im rahmen der
erkundung vor ort auch dann zu
entscheiden wie mit der brennenden
munition umgegangen wird können sie noch
mal so ein bisschen die herausforderung
beschreiben mit der sie da konfrontiert
sind aktuell haben sie so was schon mal
erlebt
also ich persönlich habe so etwas noch
nicht erlebt und viele meiner kollegen
die hier vor ort sind und auch kameraden
der freiwilligen feuerwehren auch noch
nicht das ist ein ganz besonderer
einsatz ein einsatz der geprägt ist
dadurch dass wir hier mit definierenden
munitionsresten dass wir hier mit
explosivstoffen konfrontiert werden und
deswegen natürlich schon darauf
angewiesen sind vor ort zu entscheiden
gemeinsam mit den sprengmeistern
gemeinsam mit der polizei und allen
beteiligten wie wir mit dieser
brennenden munition umgehen und als wir
heute morgen um halb vier alarmiert
worden sind und tätig geworden sind und
die ersten detonation einsätzen hat
unser einsatzleiter sofort den rückzug
befohlen weil wir auch unter
lebensgefahr uns gefunden haben und auch
noch stunden später nämlich um 18 uhr
und um 18 uhr 30 kam es zu einem großen
zu einer großen anzahl von weiteren
umsetzung so sagt der fachmann also
sprich explosionen von munitionsresten
und insofern sehen sie dass diese lage
hier noch nicht stabil ist wie konnte
denn diese situation aus ihrer sicht
entstehen war erst das feuer da oder
erst die explosion auf diesem
sprengplatz der polizei
ja das ist jetzt müßig darüber zu
philosophieren
das werden die untersuchungen zeigen
untersuchungen die durch die
brandursachenermittlungen angestellt
werden und die brandursachenermittlung
ist eine kernaufgabe in berlin der
polizei warum lagert denn überhaupt
munition in einem waldstück und in einem
naherholungsgebiet für alle
berlinerinnen berliner ist das aus
feuerwehr sicht eine gute idee
also ich kann ihnen sagen aus feuerwehr
sicht hätte die lage deutlich
deutlich schwieriger sein können nämlich
wenn insbesondere wohnbebauung sehr viel
näher angeschlossen gewesen wäre hätten
wir eine große mammut aufgabe heute zu
bewältigen gehabt nämlich die
evakuierung und auch das herumfliegen
von trümmerteilen statt mailen oder
ähnlichen resten dann entsprechend im
blick zu haben und insofern ist aus
feuerwehrtechnischer sicht die lage
dieses platzes hier im wald durchaus
vorteilhaft aber könnte man nicht
irgendwie außerhalb der großstadt viel
viel besser im griff behalten diese
ganze munition
ja auch das ist natürlich jetzt an
dieser stelle müßig zu diskutieren dann
müssen wir die verantwortlichen fragen
und verantwortlich ist nicht die
berliner feuerwehr
ich kann ihnen sagen wir wollen mit der
lage konfrontiert und wir sind hier vor
ort im rahmen der repressiven
gefahrenabwehr sagt der
landesbranddirektor von berlin carsten
homrighausen homrighausen ganz
herzlichen dank für das gespräch heute
live aus berlin
ja es ist nicht nur berlin nebenan in
brandenburg sind rund zwölf prozent der
gesamtfläche des landes mit bomben
granaten und munition belastet
gefährliches erbe aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg und von diversen
truppenübungsplätzen unter anderem der
sowjets jedes jahr müssen hunderte
tonnen kampfmittel vernichtet werden bei
richtiger hitze sagen sie dort gehen die
granaten hoch und richtige hitze haben
wir aktuell ja wirklich dazu kommt die
trockenheit die jedem wald zu setzt ganz
unabhängig davon ob dort munition
gelagert wird oder nicht brandenburg
hatte dieses jahr bereits mit schlimmen
waldbränden zu kämpfen und aktuell der
größten dürre in der geschichte des
bundeslandes die klimakrise wird das
problem noch drängender machen höchste
zeit grundsätzlich neu zu denken jan
meyer aus potsdam auch im kiefernwald
von thomas weber hat es in diesem jahr
schon gebrannt doch war das feuer
schnell gelöscht denn der förster lässt
regelmäßig tote äste und umgestürzte
bäume entfernen die flammen fanden so
wenig nahrung jetzt natürlich von der
brandlast ab also wenn ich viel
brennmaterial am boden habe wo er ist
auch eine große hitzeentwicklung
entsteht dann ist das natürlich dann
nachher eine ganz andere dynamik als
werden hier so gut wie nichts liegt nur
ein bisschen und alles ich sag mal so
vor sich hin schwelt auf dem boden oder
leicht brennt ganz anders aus in den
brandgebieten in südbrandenburg und
sachsen abgestorbenes holz am boden
sorgte mit dafür dass sich die flammen
rasend schnell ausbreiteten solche
brandbeschleuniger gibt es nicht nur
hier einige experten sehen
handlungsbedarf im ausgetrockneten
kiefernwald land brandenburg
was man in den bestehenden anderen
beständen machen kann ist dass man jetzt
unverzüglich hineingeht in diese wälder
und das totholz heraus sieht das kann
man zu hackschnitzeln oder pellets
verarbeiten das ist erneuerbare energie
und gleichzeitig den wald von dem risiko
befreien totholz sorgt im gesunden wald
für vielfalt doch brandenburg ist
hochrisikoland nirgendwo sonst brennt es
so oft hinzu kommt viele gegenden sind
munitions belastet die löscharbeiten
fordern immer mehr personal immer mehr
ausrüstung an der technischen hochschule
wildau will luftfahrttechniker wolfgang
groth der kinder bis 2024 eine neuartige
drohne entwickeln sie soll bis zu acht
stunden in der luft bleiben können und
mit einer kamera über einen brennenden
wald live informationen sammeln
es werden ja drohnen heute auch schon
eingesetzt aber bis die information im
einsatzleitwagen also bei der
einsatzleitstelle zur verfügung stellen
dauert es zu lange brandenburgs
umweltminister besuchte am nachmittag
den zerstörten kiefernwald im
elbe-elster-kreis er setzt auf den umbau
zu mischwald als bestes brandschutz
mittel doch muss der grünen politiker
eingestehen dass sein bundesland damit
immer mehr ins hintertreffen gerät das
ist eine mär generationenaufgabe wir
haben in brandenburg 600.000 hektar wald
die umgebaut werden müssen kiefern rein
kulturen so wie wir jetzt gerade in
einer stehen und wir verzeichnen dass
wir mit 5000 hektar wald umbau im jahr
eigentlich nicht weiterkommen kiefern
durch laubbäume zu ersetzen das braucht
zeit förster weber hat in seinem revier
verschiedene baumarten angepflanzt der
so entstandene kühle und feuchte
mischwald widersteht der feuergefahr
besser
selbst dann eine zigarette wegschmeißt
unbedacht dann würde hier nicht gleich
im verein ist feuer entstehen also
deswegen ist waldumbau auch alsbald
brandschutz im gebot der stunde thomas
weber wünscht sich von der politik einen
marshallplan für den wald in ganz
brandenburg in diesem jahr probiert
erreichen setzlinge aus er hofft dass
sie einmal künftigen hitzewellen noch
besser widerstehen
einen marshall-plan für den wald in
taiwan erhalten die menschen den atem an
und schauen mit sorge darauf wie china
versucht sie einzuschüchtern indem es
demonstrativ seine militärmacht zeigt
hanna damit beginnst du jetzt nur einen
tag nach dem besuch von us
spitzenpolitikerin polo sie in taiwan
hat china heute mit dem angekündigten
militärmanöver rund um die insel
begonnen es gilt als das größte seit
jahrzehnten bei den übungen feierte die
chinesische armee mehrere ballistische
raketen ab kriegsschiffe und kampfjets
sind nur wenige kilometer von der küste
im einsatz
die regierung taiwans hat unterdessen
ihr militär in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt die tr manöver china soll noch
bis sonntag dauern
seit gestern ist klar wie das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz aussehen soll und
die reaktionen darauf heute sind
gemischt der präsident der
bundesärztekammer kritisierte das
konzept als zu vage und klar sei etwa
was passieren soll wenn eine überlastung
der medizinischen infrastruktur drohe
sagte klaus reinhardt der funke
mediengruppe ähnlich äußerte sich der
chef der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft gas gelobt wurde
dagegen dass schulschließungen tabu sein
sollen
ab sofort ist es wieder möglich sich per
telefon krankschreiben zu lassen das hat
der gemeinsame bundesausschuss von
ärzten krankenkassen und kliniken
entschieden
grund sind die hohen corona zahlen wer
erkältet ist muss also nicht mehr in die
praxis kommen ärztinnen und ärzte können
ihre patienten nach einer telefonischen
befragung bis zu sieben tage
krankschreiben das gilt auch für
verlängerungen um weitere sieben tage
die sonderregel gilt erstmal bis ende
november
wegen zahlreicher vorwürfe gegen
rbb-intendantin schlesinger hat der
rundfunk berlin-brandenburg seinen
vorsitz innerhalb der ard aufgegeben
schlesinger steht unter anderem wegen
der vergabe von beraterverträgen in der
kritik und sieht sich mit dem verdacht
der vetternwirtschaft konfrontiert ihre
hauptaufgabe sei es jetzt zur aufklärung
beizutragen erklärte schlesinger die 61
jährige bleibt im amt als
rbb-intendantin den ard vorsitz
übernimmt zunächst der westdeutsche
rundfunk
nach dem angriff auf ein
kriegsgefangenenlager in der ost ukraine
bereiten die vereinten nationen eine
untersuchung vor das kündigte
un-generalsekretär guterres am
vergangenen freitag wurden bei
explosionen in dem lager laut russland
dutzende ukrainische kriegsgefangene
getötet
das gebiet wird aktuell vom russischen
militär kontrolliert moskau und kiew
machen sich gegenseitig für den angriff
verantwortlich beide hatten eine un
untersuchung beantragt
tschernobyl liegt in der ukraine und der
name allein reicht um alte ängste sofort
wieder hochkommen zu lassen
borussia liegt auch in der ukraine
es ist das größte atomkraftwerk europas
und es wird immer mehr zu einem
kriegsschauplatz
man muss kein experte sein um sich die
potenziellen folgen ausmalen zu können
heute kommen meldungen wonach russische
truppen die die atomanlage aktuell
besetzt halten von dort eine benachbarte
stadt unter beschuss genommen haben
sollen das kalkül offenbar die ukraine
können kaum zurückschießen ohne das
atomkraftwerk zu treffen keine der
beiden seiten zeigt bereitschaft sich
wenigstens auf eine sicherheitszone rund
um nuklearanlagen zu einigen sagt die
internationale atomenergiebehörde und
warnt so kann es nicht weitergehen
kamran seit jahren mit mehr
märz 2022 das größte atomkraftwerk
europas in sapporo schierstedt unter
russischen beschuss
glück im unglück damals wurden keine
reaktorblöcke oder kritischen systeme
getroffen das atomkraftwerk liegt mitten
im kriegsgebiet die situation sei
äußerst bedrohlich so die internationale
atomenergiebehörde sie warnt jetzt vor
einem möglichen nuklearunfall
die situation in sapporo ist völlig
außer kontrolle
wir haben regelmäßig informationen über
beschuss und geschosse von flugzeugen
oder drohen die unversehrtheit der
anlage ist nicht gegeben wenn wir uns
die lage in sapporo hier anschauen sehen
wir fast alle prinzipien der nuklearen
sicherheit verletzt
in der ukraine gibt es vier aktive
atomkraftwerke mit insgesamt 15
kernreaktoren saborio hat sechs
kernreaktoren von dem drei derzeit aktiv
sind das atomkraftwerk liegt im südosten
der ukraine
hier bilder von 2016 schon damals ist
die technik veraltet und wartungs
bedürftig
störfälle häufen sich
jetzt ist die anlage in russischer hand
die lieferkette für ausrüstung und
ersatzteile unterbrochen so große
wir haben die paradoxe situation dass
die anlage von russischen militär
kontrolliert wird während lokales
ukrainisches personal jeden tag seinen
dienst verrichtet das führt
unvermeidlich zu großen spannungen und
auch zu gewalt
einzelne mitarbeiter könnten verschleppt
worden sein so groß russland soll das
größte atomkraftwerk europas inzwischen
als militärbasis und schutzschild nutzen
sagt der amerikanische außenminister
russland nutzt das kraftwerk als
militärbasis um die ukraine zu
beschießen sie wissen dass die ukraine
das feuer nicht erwidern kann weil sie
sonst den nuklearreaktor oder auch hoch
radioaktives material treffen könnte
der luftraum über die ukrainische
atomanlagen sollte geschlossen werden
fordert der ukrainische vize
aussenminister top hits geht sollte das
atomkraftwerk getroffen werden droht der
worst case zu experten ja wir haben es
hier mit einer neuen dimension der
kriegsführung zu tun dass erst einmal
die große gefahr die von atomkraftwerken
ausgeht ins militärische kalkül
einbezogen wird die russische armee baut
den kraftwerksstandort zu einer
militärbasis um und die ukraine greift
das auch mit kampfdrohnen an und wenn
hier schwerer schaden passiert dann hat
man einen super-gau dann gibt es
großflächige radioaktive
belastungen die auf europa betreffen
können um das zu verhindern fordert die
internationale atomenergiebehörde jetzt
dringend zugang zum von der russischen
armee besetzten atomkraftwerk in sapporo
dass ein staat mit atomkraftwerken einem
umfassenden angriffskrieg eines anderen
staates ausgesetzt ist das hat es im
laufe der zivilen nutzung der
kernenergie noch nie gegeben sagt die
internationale atombehörde
daher seien die möglichen folgen nicht
realistisch bewertbar das klingt alles
andere als gut
mitten in die schwierigen weltlage ist
die amerikanische basketball
topspielerin britney kreiner geraten sie
hatte zwei e zigaretten mit cannabis öl
im gepäck und muss jetzt wegen
drogenschmuggels in russland neun jahre
hinter gitter sie flehte die russischen
richter an aber die kannten keine gnade
jetzt bleibt ihr nur die hoffnung auf
einen gefangenenaustausch
und präsident biden gerät enorm unter
druck claudia bertz berichtet
traurig und schockiert reagiert britney
greiner als die richterin das urteil
verkündet neun jahre straflager damit
hat das gericht fast die höchststrafe
verhängt ist der anklage weitgehend
gefolgt und hat die argumente der
verteidigung fast vollständig außer acht
gelassen
britney greiner hatte vor der verkündung
nochmals betont sie habe ohne vorsatz
gehandelt
ich habe einen arglosen fehler gemacht
und ich hoffe dass ihr urteil mein leben
nicht hier beendet jeder spricht darüber
ich sei ein politisches unterpfand über
politische spielchen aber ich hoffe dass
das diesem gericht fern liegt
flughafen moskau hier kamen sie an um in
der amerikanischen basketball spielpause
für eine russische mannschaft zu spielen
bei der kontrolle ihres gepäcks war das
cannabis öl gefunden worden sie habe
schnell gepackt gedankenlos sagte
greiner cannabis bräuchte sie manchmal
gegen schmerzen die us-regierung wirft
russland ein politisch motiviertes
verfahren vor
das ist ein fehlurteil das
us-außenministerium hat festgestellt
dass mir einer zu unrecht inhaftiert ist
nichts an diesem urteil ändert diese
einschätzung außenminister blinken der
nationale sicherheitsrat und die gesamte
us regierung sind entschlossen mit einer
sicher nach hause zu bringen zu ihren
freunden und angehörigen
die us regierung hat dafür bereits einen
gefangenenaustausch angeboten ist bereit
den in den usa inhaftierten russischen
waffenschmuggler viktor bout zu
übergeben im austausch für ihn soll
russland britney kreiner freilassen und
den ebenfalls in russland inhaftierten
amerikaner pro willen aber russland
fordert nach us angaben mehr als nur
viktor bot auch der berliner tiergarten
mörder der im auftrag staatlicher
russischer stellen gemordet hat solle
freigelassen werden
ich wäre geschockt wenn er teil des
austauschs werden würde aber das ist die
russische taktik sie fordern immer erst
mal noch mehr immer bis zur letzten
sekunde das ist meine erfahrung also
vielleicht posieren sie nur um am ende
einen deal zu kriegen
präsident biden äußerte sich nach dem
urteil gegen rainer schriftlich
russland hält britney zu unrecht fest
das ist inakzeptabel und ich fordere
russland auf sie sofort freizulassen
damit sie bei ihrer frau ihren
angehörigen freunden und teamkollegen
sein kann
ich liebe meine familie sagt sie als sie
abgeführt wird und will in berufung
gehen
für begeisterte moskau korrespondentin
für guten abend das ist ein sehr hartes
urteil wie viel politik ist dabei
also auf den besitz und die einfuhr von
cannabis da stehen in russland fünf bis
zehn jahre haft und innerhalb dieses
rahmens bewegt sich auch das urteil aber
in fällen wo der oder die angeklagte
nicht staatsangehörige eines sogenannten
unfreundlichen staates ist und dazu
gehören eben die usa aber auch
deutschland da fallen die urteile schon
regelmäßig sehr viel niedriger aus und
das russland politisches kapital
schlagen will aus diesem fall das wurde
spätestens letzte woche klar als nämlich
die außenminister von russland und
amerika miteinander telefonierten das
war der erste direkte so hochrangige
kontakt den die beiden länder hatten
seitdem russland in die ukraine
einmarschiert ist und thema dieses
telefonat war ebenfalls der fall greiner
und ein möglicher gefangenenaustausch
ist denn abschätzbar für die
wahrscheinlich so ein
gefangenenaustausch ist bei dem jahr
dann wie wir gerade im film gesehen
haben offenbar auch deutschland gefragt
sein könnte
ja also washington scheint bereit zu
sein den russischen waffenhändler viktor
bout einzutauschen der soll rebellen und
autokraten in der ganzen welt mit
illegalen waffen versorgt haben und
dafür möchte washington eben greiner und
polen einen amerikaner der hier nach
einem hoch umstrittenen prozess wegen
spionage im gefängnis sitzt das scheint
russland nicht zu reichen und man
fordert eben laut amerikanischen angaben
hier auch die freilassung oder die
auslieferung des tiergarten mörders also
jenes mannes der laut überzeugung eines
deutschen gerichtes in berlin einen
georgier erschossen haben soll und das
eben auftrag staatlicher russischer
stellen moskau hat das übrigens bisher
immer abgestritten in diesen fall
verwickelt zu sein und jetzt sagt
washington eben das moskauer jetzt
diesen
verurteilten mörder in aus einem
drittstaat in den deal aufnehmen will
damit würde moskau diese ein sehr ernst
gemeintes angebot von washington der
seite unterlaufen und es ist also so
hier läuft ein poker um diesen
gefangenenaustausch und russland pokert
sehr hoch interessante
hintergrundinformationen wir werden
weiter berichten viertel für heute abend
ganz herzlichen dank nach moskau
die lufthansa rechnet nach der korona
krise mit mehr als einer halben
entschuldigung mit mehr als einer halben
milliarde euro gewinn im laufenden jahr
sie rechnet auch mit weiteren massiven
problemen und mit abfertigungs chaos und
sie guckt gebannt heute auf ein hotel am
frankfurter flughafen hat ganz genau
denn dort wurde verhandelt und seit
wenigen minuten ist klar erfolgreich
lufthansa und die gewerkschaft verdi
konnten sich in den tarifverhandlungen
für das bodenpersonal einigen stefanie
bareth in frankfurt ist bin schon
bekannt worauf genau ja also das haben
wir ganz frische erfahren und ganz
offensichtlich können lufthansa-kunden
aufatmen die tarifparteien haben die kuh
vom eis geräumt und einen durchbruch im
tarifkonflikt erzielt laut verdi sollen
die 20.000 boden beschäftigten der
lufthansa eine gehaltserhöhung in drei
schritten erhalten zunächst einen
festbetrag von 200 euro monatlich
rückwirkend ab ersten juli vom ersten
januar an dann weitere zweieinhalb
prozent und mindestens 125 euro
monatlich und nochmals 2,5 prozent ab
juli nächsten jahres bei der laufzeit da
hat sich die lufthansa ganz
offensichtlich durchgesetzt sie betreten
und 18 monate die gewerkschaft hatte
ursprünglich zwölf monate gefordert um
im falle steigender inflation die tarife
schneller anpassen zu können aber wer
die zeigt sich mit dem ergebnis
zufrieden und hat die lufthansa heute
aber noch für weitere schlagzeilen
gesorgt zum ersten mal seit corona seit
beginn der korona panini schreibt das
unternehmen wieder schwarze zahlen ganz
genau ich jetzt wo der tarifkonflikt
abgeräumt scheint könnte das für die
lufthansa gleich ein doppelter grund zum
feiern sein denn der konzern hat sich
wie du gesagt hast aus der tiefsten
luftfahrt krise der nachkriegszeit
wieder zurück gearbeitet in die
gewinnzone im zweiten quartal also von
april bis juni für das unternehmen
unterm strich rund 260 millionen euro
gewinn ein vergangenes jahr stand er um
diese zeit noch ein verlust von etwa 760
millionen euro in den büchern im
passagiergeschäft da wurden zwar wieder
viel mehr tickets verkauft für einen
überschuss hat es aber da nicht gereicht
für den gewinn ist vor allem das
frachtgeschäft verantwortlich also die
lufthansa cargo die flog schon letztes
jahr rekordgewinn ein und will dass
dieses jahr auch wieder holen beim
personal da will die lufthansa bis zum
kommenden jahr 10.000 neue beschäftigte
einstellen um die engpässe zu beheben da
kann man nur viel glück wünschen anleger
zumindest teilten heute diesen
optimismus und schoben die
lufthansa-aktie an die spitze im mdax
mit einem plus von 6,4 prozent
der positive ausblick der lufthansa
geschäftsleitung überrascht trotzdem
dennoch ist die großwetterlage von
vielen krisen bestimmt danke stefanie
nach frankfurt
die britische notenbank hat den leitzins
erneut angehoben und zwar kräftig um
einen halben prozentpunkt auf 1,75
prozent so einen deutlichen schritt gab
es im vereinten königreich vereinigten
königreich seit den 90er jahren nicht
mehr hintergrund ist die anhaltend hohe
inflation in großbritannien zuletzt lag
sie bei 9,4 prozent es ist eine traurige
zwischenbilanz in diesem badesommer bis
ende juli sind in deutschland laut der
dlrg bereits mindestens 199 menschen
ertrunken das sind 15 opfer mehr als im
vorjahreszeitraum und hat laut der
deutschen lebensrettungsgesellschaft
auch etwas mit dem frühen start der
badesaison zu tun denn schon im mai zog
es viele menschen ins kühle wasser zu
den meisten unfällen sei es an
unbewachten flüssen seen und badestellen
gekommen
die stadt ist ja bekannt für seine
naturgewalten jetzt ist dort wieder ein
vulkan im südwesten des landes
ausgebrochen seit gestern sprudelt lava
aus einer etwa 300 meter langen
erdspalten das lockt viele schaulustige
in das gebiet nahe der hauptstadt
reykjavik offen bleibt wie lange der
ausbruch dauert im vergangenen jahr
spuckte dort ein vulkan fast ein halbes
jahr lang immer wieder lava
und wir können ihnen jetzt noch eine
reise bieten und ihre bilder gemeinsam
mit zdf südamerika korrespondent
christoph böcker rat geht es durch die
geheimnisvollen anderen ans offizielle
ende der welt wo die berge versinken in
den eisigen fluten des südatlantiks wie
klingt das direkt nach uns und damit
schicken wir sie in eine heiße
sommernacht und empfehlen ihnen außerdem
noch das heute-journal update gegen 0.30
mit christopher wehrmann von uns allen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die
außergewöhnliche hitze des heutigen
tages wird abgedrängt von dieser
kaltfront die uns von nordwesten her
erreichte und in den nächsten stunden
für heftige schauer und gewitter sorgen
wird davor kommt weiterhin heiße luft
aus dem süden zu uns und so wird es
morgen im süden wieder bis zu 35 grad
geben schauen uns die details an in der
nacht also heftige gewitter von
nordwesten und westen her diese gewitter
sind durchaus dem unwetter bereich mit
hagel sturmböen und viel ringen kurzer
zeit im südosten ist es ruhig und da
funkeln die sterne bei temperaturen bis
14 grad minimum im norden und 22 grad
zum beispiel im osten dort gibt es also
nur tropische nacht sowie richtung rhein
main gebiet morgen vormittag weitere
heftige schauer und gewitter im westen
und im norden ganz im süden wieder
sonnig aber zum nachmittag verlagert
sich die kaltfront weiter nach süden und
dann müssen im süden mit teilweise
unwetter an rechnen wieder mit hagel
sturmböen und platzregen von nordwesten
her wird es allmählich ruhiger bei
höchsten temperaturen im süden noch mal
bis 35 grad vor allem die richtung
bayern 34 grad richtung neiße und 20
grad am kühlsten richtung nordsee die
kommenden tage schauer und gewitter gibt
es noch am samstag im süden bis 27 grad
oder ab sonntag steigen die temperaturen
schon wieder an ein schöner abend
[Musik]